it's an absolutely devastating time I
mean we see two million people die 36
million people more hounded either for
supposed political crimes sometimes just
really accidents of birth they were
perhaps born into a landlord's family
you've actually seen more devastating
moments in China if you just count the
death toll but I think what's really
staggering about the cultural revolution
is that it ripples out across the whole
country and it affects everybody and
it's felt at the most intimate level as
well so it begins as an Emperor's
reassertion of power Mao is worried
about his position following the Great
Leap Forward he launched this attempt to
industrialize and collectivize the
economy but it was just so insanely sort
of hubristic that it ends in complete
disaster and in every classroom and
every bedroom and every breakfast table
by the end of it isn't it yeah I mean
tens of millions of people die in the
Great Leap Forward he's worried about
his position he's worried about his
legacy
um and he sets out to eradicate any form
of opposition within the party but he
does this critically by bringing in the
masses by using this Mass sentiment
there's already a personality cult
that's built up around him you know Mao
is the Red Son in our hearts he's he is
there everywhere I mean you wake up in
the morning he's on the pillows he's on
your mirror
um he uses this extraordinary veneration
in which he's held and he wields it
against the party and so both of his
heirs apparent will die before the
decade is out
um but because it's carried out through
the people
uh it ripples out and we see Farmers
dying we see not just revered Scholars
and artists dying but infants even in
some cases being killed because of their
sort of class background as horrific
um
as that is
and
so
it's the intimate treacheries I think
that that play out that are often really
sort of the most devastating people it's
when husbands are turning on wives it's
when colleagues and friends are sort of
turning upon each other sort of
households really ripped apart by this
and that in some ways is I think what
people find it hard is to move past and
also because it sort of moves at such
dizzying speed it's hard to keep up with
and this is an ideological Crusade for
Mao as well he wants to purify the
nation purifies its hearts and souls
make these people into the sort of the
real Communists he believes they should
be
and as this ripples out we just sort of
see these extraordinary levels of
further that are impossible to for us to
understand I mean things like um
police at one point directing traffic
with copies of the Little Red Book
rather than batons because only Mao's
words can show you where to go it's a a
level of absurdity and horror combined
that is really sort of hard for us to
imagine I think it's a kind of religious
fanaticism isn't it it really is yes
um and it begins Mao uses as his shock
troops not just the people but
specifically young people and and
children we're talking very young
teenagers some sort of 13 or 14. we see
these sort of political vigilante groups
forming red guards who sweep through the
cities and tear down temples but also
are beating and murdering teachers and
Scholars and artists and so forth It's a
just a horrific moment and then as it
ripples out
we see factional fighting between them
and even when that initial wave of Red
Guard violence is over then we go on to
see this sort of factional turmoil and a
more orderly but in fact in some ways
more deadly uh phase of people being
executed as counter-revolutionaries or
for supposedly being involved in
conspiracies which in some cases we're
told that you know these conspiracies
are so Sinister because they don't even
know they're a part of it so let's talk
about individual lives then because this
comes down even in a country of 1.4
billion people to to two individuals as
you've explained um so articulately
um you you wrote the book through
interviewing and of course these people
are now in their 50s or 60s who lived
through it as teenage shock troops um
what did they say about it what were
their Recollections and how did they
relive
well of course many people most people
don't really want to talk about it
um and what fascinated me was that there
were these people who didn't necessarily
want to talk about it but I think felt
they had to
um
and so it's a very mixed picture there
are people who still think the cultural
revolution was right and the only really
thing that really went wrong with it was
that it ended and yes there shouldn't
have been so much violence but Mao was
quite right to sort of believe in this
purity
um there are also people
um who are deeply reflective about what
they did
um so I start the book
um really where I began in finding out
about the cultural revolution uh with a
painter called shui Shin a wonderful
painter who's done these immense sort of
Two and a Half meter tall portraits of
people who died in the cultural
revolution
and he told me that the the first in the
series as far as he was concerned was
the very first picture he remembers
drawing at the age of seven or eight
um he'd been told that his school
teacher who he liked very much was
actually the daughter of a landlord and
he was so shocked by his naivety in the
moment that he had believed in this
lovely woman that he drew this hideous
caricature of her
and pinned it up to the Blackboard
and she walked in and saw it and he says
he just remembers her turning white
because of course at that point as a
small child he didn't really realize
where it could lead but even that early
in the cultural revolution it was very
clear to her that it could mean disgrace
being ousted and ultimately of course
many teachers paid their prices price
with their lives
so that was a a drawing but you you also
went on to others who
um
denounced actively denounced teachers or
were involved in violence yes absolutely
and who are now trying to reckon with
that
um and I think in many cases find it
hard even as they dress it address it
perhaps
to fully acknowledge everything all the
full implications of what they did I
mean they struggle with it very
understandably I think it would be easy
for people perhaps to judge them
um but I don't think any of us can
imagine what it was like to be 13 or 14
years old to have this man that you
revered as a god telling you that it was
your duty to see this this chaos unfurl
around you and in many cases I mean one
of the most striking things to me
um
was uh my sort of first interview in the
book who was a young girl at the time
talking about how she felt at the time
that she wasn't brave enough because she
wasn't willing to beat teachers up you
know she was attending these things but
she wasn't social in the moment she felt
she did she felt it wasn't right she
felt it wasn't right but there was also
a part of her that was thinking you know
should I be doing this why am I am I
just not strong enough
so if she didn't beat her teachers why
is she still obsessing about the
cultural revolution now revisiting it in
her mind
stage even criticizing a teacher could
sort of open the door
to so much worse
um being a red guard seeing what was
happening going to struggle sessions
um and I think as well the ambivalence
because in some ways for her it was a
time of great Freedom she was a young
teenage girl and she was traveling the
country with her friends she said in
some ways at times it felt almost more
like sightseeing or a holiday and yet at
the same time they also believed that
they were on this revolutionary Mission
and it was their Duty
to bring the country to this kind of
state of Israel because it's got not
just the Savage blood bars and the
struggle sessions but it's also got
aspects of Music Festival and Inter
railing holiday and young people kind of
having fun together yeah and it's very
hard for us to imagine and I think as I
said very easy to judge but I think it's
just impossible for us to know what we
would have done in those circumstances
especially really difficult I was just
listening to you and thinking how
difficult it would it be to try to
re-explore the map of what was going on
when there's no actual historical
context that is freely available or
discussed or processed as a society
you've got nothing you've got nowhere to
kind of anchor yourself have you as you
explore exactly and I think some of
these people spoke out precisely because
at the time I started writing we were
seeing a few more voices becoming uh
evident partly I think of the internet
it was easier to share your story yeah I
found that really interesting because I
made the documentary Series in 1996 on
the 30th anniversary of the outbreak of
the cultural revolution which is
obviously a pre-internet age and then it
was very interesting to me to read your
interviews which are slightly post the
arrival of the internet yes I think
there was that sense that people were
more able to speak out and that was
encouraging others but also I think age
perhaps getting older and thinking about
what happened and wanting to record it
and that sense that it just wasn't
anywhere there
in society
um
so what sort of marks the people in the
book out I guess are they they are the
ones who want to talk about it whether
because they believe that actually there
are positive lessons to be learned from
the cultural revolution as bizarre as
that might sound to us you know they
they see it as a time when they were
able to speak out
um in a way they couldn't now and they
see it as a time when there was greater
respect for working people and less
inequality and so forth
um so I think in many cases as well it's
it's driven by their view of the present
inevitably part of the urge to speak out
about what happened then is a sense of
what the present is like and what it
could be and for people on the other
side of the argument who see the
cultural revolution as a warning
that's part of it too they think well if
we don't remember it we may end up
repeating it
um and so for those reasons two people
want to keep it alive and then for some
people it's so deeply personal so
um in the case of the young man who
denounced his mother I mean he was 17 he
sent her to her death he and his father
by revealing that she'd denounce
Chairman Mao and
I don't think many of us could
live with that knowledge
um so to him he wanted to keep that
alive to protect his mother's grave
initially and perhaps just to
be true to his memory of her in a way
that he hadn't been able to be true to
her when she was alive completely I mean
to say something critical of chair Mao
in those days was was to do something
that would uh would definitely endanger
your life it was suicidal I mean because
I think it's very hard for people to
imagine
the kind of things that could get you
into trouble in those days I mean for
example you know people would sort of
dutifully write down Chairman Mao quotes
but maybe they'd get a character wrong
and someone would say well you did that
on purpose so even when you were trying
to sort of do the right thing in their
terms or Lord it was there were just
these pitfalls all the way I mean it was
an incredibly sort of treacherous
terrain and that and that sense of
absolute danger everywhere in every
relationship in everywhere you went in
life and and the sense I suppose you
know just going back to a point you were
making earlier about the the reasons why
it happened and what man wanted to do
actually it took on a life of its own
didn't it and all kinds of you know
unintended consequences as well as the
intended consequences happen to the
extent that the revolution began to eat
its own children
perpetrators became victims became
perpetrators rather like in this family
and nobody knew
how to navigate during that decade and
so you just see a nation that's hugely
traumatized still
and that struggles to come to terms with
what people have done what was done to
them
in some cases I think even really the
sort of the rehabilitations that
followed afterwards almost sort of made
it worse because there were people who
sort of found a way to rationalize it by
thinking well I must have done something
wrong and I got it wrong and then to
discover after all that of course they
hadn't and it was just the zealotry
the paranoia of the moment was in a way
almost sort of more devastating to them